watts e bevo qualche un vj hem today we
are in the foresta come sempre la vita
che sto cercando uno sfondo dei 100 mo
lo trovo quindi cercherò uno sfondo
decente anzi sempre nei commenti che
risponde che sfondi volete ma giochiamo
ragazzo livelli nel video di oggi o una
chicca particolare siamo sul microsoft
volevo fare una specie già la come si
presenta e fantastico vogliamo fare una
specie di parkour è un po strano perché
agli asset e single player ace il tasto
start ma per uno strato d'acqua
vabbè è un percorso fatto da qualcuno e
lo giochi da solo
grazie di aver fatto le scritte che
escono fuori dallo schermo così non
leggo una sega la donna mai gigante non
ce la farò mai finirla in un video solo
e proviamoci le alghe e la partenza è
fantastica vi ringrazio alla volevo
vedere perché è la prima volta che
faccio un parco da solo e ogni volta che
faccio parkour io sono abbastanza c'è me
la cavo perché c'è pietro dietro di me
quindi so che devo scappare come porco
demonio porco devo scappare tantissime
quindi è per questo che è che vinco
perché c'è pietro che se mi raggiunge mi
butta giù
adesso mamma mia
siccome non c'è né pietro né nessun
altro devo provare da solo
ah ok ok ok e li cominciare i pali è
tutto un altro paio di giri di mazza ok
non ci credo eccolo all e la prima parte
l'abbiamo fatta c'è poi non so se
funziona aspettati un imbuto ma vi fa
ripartì da zero e invece funziona
perfetto bene ragazzi
la prima parte l'abbiamo fatta andiamo
alla prossima dai ragazzi forza devo
credere in me stesso con l'edizione solo
quando c'è pietro vinco lo invito a casa
giochiamo stop alcol parola faccio il
singolo croce lui che mi alita al collo
sul collo ok ok molto buono
qua devo tirare questo per fare questo
profilo perfetto orca vacca quello check
point regata io ho la mia vita fa schifo
mannaia pietro niente non riesco a
saltare sui cosi non riesco a trattarci
così perfetto per no non sono capace
perché lo so
faccio giocare minecraft una volta molto
più bravo allora ho fatto spira al
parkour ho fatto parkour paradise ho
fatto parkour pyramid ho fatto tutti
parkour di questo mondo
riuscirò a fare questo parkour che un
parco di single player la risposta è sì
ok ok e come affrontare john cena al
brest ling poi su realpower o perfetto
c'è poi c'è uno slang gigantesco perché
c'è una cassa quale easter egg ford
preston cosa vuol dire solo di così star
ma la sorella viola ci sia arrivato non
ci credo ci sono arrivato non pensavo
meglio arrivarci perfetto ma c'è un
blocco verde
non so se ci arrivo ok ci sono arrivato
ok ci sono arrivato adesso muoio tratto
è rimasto lì cosa che tirando giù solo
fare qua
porca vacca salta un sacco sta roba ed è
questo che questo cosa che fa fa
qualcosa che non ho capito
aumenta la fox tipo cos'è ma cosa fa
e difficile non lo è allora non ho
capito cosa ha fatto il blocco ma è
difficilissimo starci sopra allora dài
maledizione dai buono no perché ora vito
fa schifo è difficilissimo dai ragazzi è
un casino cv giuro a dio mio
c'è quella fare si rompe capito che ci
sei sopra si rompe ma non sono anche
riuscito a ritornarci guarda ma dai
c'è proprio su statisti pezzenti vabbè
dai neo anti cosa
raga io non sto cliccando niente cosa
sta succedendo cos'è sta roba
stranissima
c'è una roba che ti porta giù in su a
caso due cose che devo fare qui scusami
ma ecco ok non ho capito cosa ho fatto
ma va bene no io ho bisogno di pietro
nei palco ragazzi senza pietro ho dei
problemi perfetto grazie
ok ok fermi che devo capire ho capito ho
capito benissimo sono forte checkpoint
vi prego grazie non ha senso per me
esistere se cade un'altra volta lì come
ho fatto che ci sono i blocchi che
cadono qua come faccio a sapere cos'è
che cade
io mi o la mia vita veramente dio venite
a registrare poi i miei video io
riguardo perché devo saltare su dei
prezzi perfetto ho fatto cose strane
vabbè bureau bri ago
allora il costo del never senti è già
difficile questo gioco in sé per favore
mamma mia quanto mi sono creato dall
allora con l'ultimo salto e poi c'è il
check point e ce l'ho fatta
stavo cadendo però non fa niente bene ci
sono le tnt questo gioco si sta
rivelando veramente brutto però va bene
gli avanti non ho capito dove dovrei
andare una volta arrivato qua sopra
non è che devo arrivare sopra lì senza
mamma mia ragazzi cosa ho fatto che non
è anche sicuro che si dovesse fare così
a questa sarà una trave di colera perché
mi fa volare esatto proprio devo andare
salto direttamente a ecco ecco ho capito
ho capito ho capito praticamente ragazzi
devo saltare le arrivarci volo perché
sta roba mi fa lievitare capito fa
levitare e mi fa cadere quindi devo
andare lì ok
mammamia what a player nessun può però
vabbè ok ma veramente sono caduto alla
fine ma dai
ok il calcolo cadeva sicuro che aveva
ragazzi mi sto sudando veramente
veramente ho bisogno di della bibbia per
fini sul livello andiamo avanti
allora dove abbiamo seguo la strada che
va risotto molto bene la partenza è
stata incredibile allora 12
niente deve saltare subito da questo
affare quando la ritenete al blocco dopo
perfetto per che cosa fare cade solo non
te lo fanno vedere però cade dalla
sicuro poi c'è una scala che può andare
al contrario non ho capito sta roba
della scala ma va bene ma va bene che
provate incredibili perfetto
questo mi fa a cavolo forse ho capito è
difficile ma ho capito fenomeno un
fenomeno cdp io sono fatto a pixel
quelli di minecraft mi hanno elogiato
perché sono il miglior parkour ista che
esista fa anche rima ragazzi ho fatto
sto salto al primo tentativo non so come
va bene sono contento
no io non ho ancora capito se perché
dura per un tot erano così invisibili
porca vacca
io non ho capito secondo ti avvicini
alle scale dei premere shift o no va
bene allora vi riuscì a fa sta roba devo
andare qui sopra il ferretto subito
salto sul ferretto salta su ferretto su
quello giusto salta sul ferretto
perfetto e la rima c'è anche stavolta ci
sono dei blocchi visibili ma che
tocchiamo a perché vuoto lì all'inizio
del gioco come gli odo stata verso
l'altro ferretto ma cavolo ma con le
all'inizio del parkour che ho iniziato
come faccio salta sul fiorentino qui
cavolo e devo andare lì e se cado ha
iniziato rifarmi tutto il gioco
mamma mia ragazzi e caga che caga
incredibile ce l'ho fatta ora va beh
cosa che ha messo abbastanza semplice
perfetto perfetto qua devo fare di corsa
no no questi così mi facevano schizza in
avanti a posto
ce l'ho fatta check point ragazzi mi sto
pagando veramente addosso ma veramente
figo
però adesso veramente figo va bene di
avanti tra l'altro io non posso spaccare
questi blocchi poi mi sa perché sono in
creative per lo potresti fare però
sarebbe citare quindi evitiamo molto
figo aveva dai questo era semplice dai
volti tutti i livelli che mi hai fatto
fare questa cagata qua fi e un insulto a
domandare sono sui neri va bene va bene
una sega sembrava facile perfetto
adesso devo andare lì a c'è un altro di
quei cosi che ti fa volare gli fa volare
è devo ricordarmi dove vai dritto dritto
dritto dritto ok adesso qua sopra pa
sopra con stop piano fi wi fi block jump
questa non so che cos'è un ceppo in
perfetto ordine file wp perfetto già
sbagliato a è un salto fatto di cinque
blocchi c'e nel senso da saltare cinque
blocchi impossibile ma non puoi farlo mi
sa che nel prossimo episodio mito pietro
perché mi sa un po di sfida maggiore
vediamo se può darmi una mano
teoricamente no però vabbè chissenefrega
quello che vi sia piaciuto supportate mi
supporta e noi ci vediamo
iscrivetevi sono stati scritti ma dopo
ne stavo ha dimenticato da ragazzi
[Musica]